uh donald trump over the weekend carried
newspapers around like a prop
this was advanced damage control for an
interview that's going to be aired
tonight
during which donald trump is confronted
about whether he reads and there are
about
three different angles to this story the
primary angle
is we are getting crushed on coronavirus
due to trump's failed response
and he's still golfing all the time
trump golfed on
saturday and he golfed on sunday he was
supposedly signing a new health care
bill into law yesterday sunday
he golfed instead no new health care
bill but on top of it
trump continues to be concerned with the
optics of carrying around newspapers
rather than actually doing something
about coronavirus so let's go through it
saturday trump golfed and he was spotted
getting out of his vehicle
carrying just a whole pile of newspapers
he also had a really strange bruise on
his hand which led to new speculation
about some medical issues but that's
that's not even the focus today
but trump had this pile of newspapers
that he was carrying around
now we've been care covering trump's
reading for years
and it would not be news to many of you
but because of the russian bounty story
trump's reading is back in the news and
in an interview coming out
tonight with axios jonathan swann
trump is confronted about whether he
reads does he read his own presidential
daily briefings and part of the reason
why
is that as far as multiple reports have
outlined
trump was briefed multiple times about
the russian bounty stories
although trump is claiming that he was
not
and so in this interview we got a clip
of it last week it's publishing tonight
donald trump claimed that he has the
best reading comprehension
of anybody that jonathan swann had
interviewed here's that clip from last
week they released a preview of
tonight's interview
i wouldn't mind if it reached my desk i
would have done something about it
it never reached my desk because do you
read your recent brief i do
i read it a lot you know i read a lot
they like to say i don't read i read a
lot
uh i comprehend extraordinarily well
probably better than anybody that you've
interviewed in a long time
uh i read a lot i spend a lot of time
with
at meetings so first of all when your
president
and people don't even believe that you
read
things have gone very very wrong there
was no reason to question
that barack obama read a lot george w
bush
didn't have to like him i didn't like
him but he read
i think it was like a book a week or a
book every two weeks there was no
question that these former presidents
read
trump doesn't read and as far as we know
he hasn't read an entire
book cover to cover in his entire adult
life
but trump always goes to f too far he
doesn't just say i read
he says my reading comprehension is
better than anyone you've interviewed
recently
what what does this have to do with who
jonathan swann
has interviewed and likewise now the
calculated advanced damage control of
trump being photographed with newspapers
also goes too far
he's carrying a gigantic stack like if
we were to believe that trump looked at
one newspaper
okay maybe but the idea that trump is
reading a stack of newspapers on his
ride to play golf
is too silly to even be plausible
everything is posturing everything is
pretense and optics
and if anything trump is looking at the
pictures
in the newspapers maybe he's looking at
like a headline or two
the bible he clearly doesn't read it he
said it was his favorite book along with
his own book
now there's another side to the story
that i want to briefly mention
there was a ton of speculation that
trump went to walter reed hospital over
the weekend
for either unknown reasons or as a
supposed cerebral event
and that the bruise on his hand in the
picture is from having an iv
and that the newspapers were actually
just meant to kind of cover the bruise
which didn't work
there is no evidence that that's what
happened the white house says he didn't
go to walter reed
you know that when things have been
fishy with trump's
medical status i've told you about it
until we get actual evidence that this
is what happened
it's much more likely that trump just
wants to be seen holding newspapers to
create this idea that he reads
knowing that tonight there's a major
interview believed to be
very damaging to donald trump being
published by axios
during which the topic of trump's
reading comes up i think the simplest
explanation
is the accurate explanation here and uh
if we get other evidence to the contrary
you know i will be here telling you
about it
let me tell you real quick about one of
our sponsors cuts
clothing they offer super quality men's
t-shirts and they're giving you 15 off
when you go to davidpakman.com cuts
that's
c-u-t-s because solid color
t-shirts are a really important staple
in pretty much every guy's wardrobe
i think it's really important not to
overlook the value of having t-shirts
you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with
are men's solid color t-shirts so they
actually put a ton of thought
into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts i've owned
and they look great this right here that
i'm wearing
uh on youtube is the split hem
crew neck t-shirt very soft
fits me perfectly it's the ideal length
go take a look at what they offer and
once you have it
you are really going to see and feel the
difference
their slogan is it's the only shirt
worth wearing
you will see why and you'll get 15 off
when you do it
by going to davidpakman.com cuts
that's davidpakman.com c-u-t-s